hello everybody and welcome to part 4 of
a Raspberry Pi tutorial series in this
tutorial what we're doing is just kind
of going over the navigation commands of
the Linux terminal so if you're already
familiar with these you can feel free to
skip this tutorial if you want if you're
not familiar well this tutorial is for
you so the first thing that we're going
to cover is just like to figure out
where you are in the terminal you can
use PWD which is print working directory
so we can do that and we can see ok
we're at slash home slash PI so
generally when you log in you're going
to log in to your users root directory
so in this case that's username is PI so
slash home slash PI also just for the
record I'll probably forget to mention
this but if you're looking at commands
online for doing things a lot of times
you'll see dollar sign and then it'll
say like sudo apt-get or whatever the
dollar sign is not something you type
it's there to reference this dollar sign
on the command line unfortunately you
can't see my mouse but I'm pointing to
that blue dollar sign
so anyway okay there's that now the next
thing I want us to go ahead and do is
generally a slash home slash PI you
never really have to type that out you
can use also it's got blue Tildy you can
use that as well so you can reference
your users root directory just with
tilde
now next thing you can do is change
directories with CD so you change
directories you can type where you want
to go so we could go to home now we're
on home and you can see home now this
blue here is home we can go back to
where we were with CD tilde ok so once
we're there the next thing I want to
show is to list the contents of a
directory you use LS hit enter and just
in case I forget to you can hit the up
arrow to do the last commands so we can
kind of cycle through so up arrow is LS
again CD again home the other thing I
might forget is the kind of tab complete
so /h OH and then you can hit tab and it
will finish it off if there's multiple
choices
like for example there you can hit tab a
couple of times a little just kind of
output all the choices you could have
okay so LS will list out all the
directories in this case we just have
I'm sorry to list all the contents in a
directory in this case all we have are
directories but yeah so now we're going
to do is make our own new directory to
make a new directory we can do m'kay
dirt and we'll call the directory
example we can check out the contents
again and sure enough there's our new
example directory so we can change into
that directory now a CD TX tab example
good and maybe we didn't want to be here
so we can actually go back a directory
with CD dot dot and we go back a
directory and then let's say note we
actually wanted to be in there and let's
see the example we can actually go back
to directories by doing CD dot dot slash
dot and then you can put the slash or
not doesn't matter but now we're back
home we can even go back again another
directory now we're actually in the root
directory of the raspberry pi this is a
pretty dangerous place to be we don't
really want to be here so we're going to
get back to car safe place now we're
going to do is we're just going to
example and then now we're going to make
a file there's lots of different ways
lots of different editors to use I
prefer Nano a lot of people refer them
it really doesn't matter use whatever
you want
I think Nano is the like simplest so I
just like to use it
Nano will do Nano test pi go ahead and
hit enter and now we're in the editor so
now what I can do is just print and then
we can say print hi and then to exit
control X yes to save will keep the same
file name cool now to run test stop PI
we're going to run it with Python we
want to use Python to run what test pot
and then sure enough we ran it also you
can just type Python and now you've got
a Python interpreter here we quit also
you can do Python 3 for python 3
specifically so we could also use Python
test out my same thing okay so now we're
going to do is talk about getting data
from the internet so what we're going to
do is do major downloads we're going to
change directory into downloads and now
what we're going to do is we're going to
use W get to start so I'm going to go to
Python programming done that you can go
wherever you want just get an image so
I'm just going to right click this one
and copy that image address moving this
over we can get that image with W get
and then I'll right click to paste that
in also you can copy things just by
highlighting in the terminal and doing
ctrl C or you can also cut paste really
quickly with just a right-click anyway
we've downloaded that image we can
actually see it now with LS there is the
image now there the other thing is
pretty popular is going to be github so
you can clone packages and stuff from
get up so I'm going to do sudo apt-get
install git or JIT but we already have
it I think that comes default on the PI
I'm not really positive but yeah so now
what we can do is like for example we
can get trying to think well I'll just
type it out we can do get clone and in
fact excellence is do Python github
repositories trending Python
repositories such as googled Python
repositories trending wines I wanted
something short and quick none of these
are going to be very quick I don't think
but anyway we'll do awesome Python so
here we are let's say we want all of
this we can just take this URL copy come
over here
gift clone paste in that URL enter and
it's going to clone all of that into our
directory for us so now what we can do
is list out the contents of the
directory sure enough there they are we
can change directory into awesome Python
to see what we got and yes we've got all
of everything we wanted so so now what
we're going to do is let's go back
directory and let's talk about deleting
things so LS let's delete a matplotlib
PG so what we're going to do is bar m4
remove and then 3d - matplotlib PNG
enter LS it's gone the other thing like
let's what if we tried to stick it to
remove a directory in fact let me just
make a directory will click RM me LS you
can remove a directory with or endure or
I mean so and now that directory is gone
but what if we try to do our under
awesome Python it says ah we can't
remove that because it's not empty so
the next thing we could do is RM - bar
so that's remove recursively eat for in
hold on check out of Oh awesome Python
that's or a custom files I'm not
finishing ok
Thorin - are awesome Python so here we
can't we could try to say yes and yes
and let's see if it's there okay that
actually got fully removed there might
be a time where you actually need to use
sudo RM - are but in this case we didn't
actually need to do that so now we can
list out and nothing's here and in fact
let's go let me think here we could go
back now in directories there's really
nothing in here okay so now here and
there's really not too much here either
let's go back one more directory so
let's just be more so basically we're
change very basically in your home
directory now let's talk about some of
the other kind of flags and parameters
and stuff so if we do LS that lists out
the contact contents of a directory we
can also do LS - a and this is going to
be all contents including hidden
contents so suddenly we see a few more
things here we can also do LS dash L and
it's a much more pretty list format of
content
cool and then we can actually combine
these things LS - a L like that and now
it's all the contents and they're like
combined into one flag
now there's two forms of flats you've
got a single - or a double - a double -
is for forward parameters in a single -
is just single words the convention is
if you have shorthand ones like a you
also have the longhand form so a is 4
all right so you can do LS - - all and
it's the exact same thing that's just
the full word okay but don't be confused
like what if you just did - all like
that what's going to happen you should
probably be able to guess but it's that
list form because it's it's actually
three parameters but the two L's do the
exact same thing but it's kind of
combining things you can't really
combine things with this double double
like that I think it's list for the tip
no that's not it no it is for just the
hell but anyway not important so you can
combine the them like that the other
thing that you might want to do from
time to time is figure out okay what
else can I do with this command so LS -
- help hit enter and here it just lists
out all the plausible commands that are
at your disposal so that's pretty useful
to use now as we've kind of already
covered but I just want to touch on them
you've got two things right when we when
we want to update the pie so you got
apt-get update and what that does is
just updates the package list it doesn't
actually update anything it's kind of a
weird name but it's like you're updating
almost apt-get Afghan itself is kind of
updating its package list and then
you've got upgrade now this actually
installs the newer versions of packages
finally to turn off and reboot the pipe
don't hit enter after this so unless you
want to wait I'm just going to show you
them but if you want to reboot you can
just do sudo reboot if you want to
reboot or if you want to shut down you
can do sudo shutdown - eh which are
supposed now alternatively you can do -
are which will be a restart if you want
anyways that's all for now
does your just a really quick
run-through there's a lot a lot a lot
more you can learn about the terminal
but that's just a really quick kind of
dive into the basics of kind of
navigating the terminal and all of that
so in the next tutorial what we're going
to be getting into is the kind of
peripherals of the Raspberry Pi what we
can do with it so the first thing we're
going to cover is the Raspberry Pi
camera model if you want if you so
choose to get one and then after that
we're going to be getting into the GPIO
stuff like that so if you have any
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below otherwise
I will see you in the next tutorial